Evet
hepiniz hoşgeldiniz
Biz ismim Şevket şahintaş Ben taksiciyim
bilirsiniz taksiciler kısa mesafeleri
sevmez Ben de sizi 18 senelik uzun bir
yolculuğa çıkarmak istiyorum
2966 yılında İstanbul'da Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi'nin hemen yanında bir
gecekonduda doğdum Çocukluğumuz Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi'nde geçmişti Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi'nin yeşil alanlarda futbol
oynuyor meyve ağaçlarında meyveler
topluyorduk ve hatta hiç unutmam 11'li
yaşlarımız da Boğaziçi Üniversitesi'nin
anayolu üzerinde bir Çitlenbik ağacı
vardı
13 arkadaş Çitlembik toplamak için
tepesine çıkmıştık Biz Çitlembik
toplarken Bekçinin bir elinde kocaman
bir sopayla inen aşağıya diye bağırmaya
başladı hayatımda yaşadığım en korku
dolu anlardı
bu sırayla Bekçinin uzak noktalarına
atlayarak nefesimiz yettiğince koşmuştuk
ve ortaokul yılları sonrası
Ben askere gidinceye kadar oto
tamirhanesinde çalıştım askerden sonra
babamın taksisinde işe başladım yıllar
Böylece geçti
bu ta ki 38 yaşına kadar 38 yaşındayken
2004 kışı Taksim Tarlabaşı'nda müşteri
bekliyordum sabaha karşı çok soğuk bir
havaydı ben müşteri Beklerken hemen
ileride üşüyerek uyumaya çalışan bir
adam gördüm ben müşteri bekliyordum adam
üşüyerek uyumaya çalışıyordu sokakta
yaşayan bir insanın Gece nasıl Uyumaya
çalıştığına ilk defa tanıklık etmiştim
bu sokakta yaşayan insanları bir Biz
gündüz görüyorduk ama onlar sanki hep
gördüğümüz yerdeler nasıl gördüyse hep
Oradalar ne şekilde gördüyse Sanki onlar
hep oradaydı lar kaldırım taşı elektrik
direği gibi gecesini hiç düşünmemiştik
ya ben bu gördüğüm gerçekliği bütün
insanlara Özellikle de yetkililere
göstermem gerektiğini düşündüm
ama bunu nasıl yapacaktın
bu fotoğraf makinesi ile bunu
yapabileceğimi düşündüm ama şöyle bir
gerçeklik vardı Ben hayatım boyunca hiç
fotoğraf çekmemiştim
vb fotoğrafa karşı olan ilgi ve bilgim
Türk fotoğrafının en Duayen ismi ara
Güler'i dahi tanımıyordum
15.6 kompakt küçük bir fotoğraf makinesi
aldım Kot pantolonun önce bine
sığmıyordu
var Ancak
stratejilerde belirlemem gerekiyordu
sokakta yaşayan insanları çekebilmek
için
ilk öncelikle yapmam gereken sokakta
yaşayan O insanları Hani tuğlalar üst
üste koyduğumuzda nasıl duvar oluşuyorsa
Ben de fotoğraflardan bir duvar
oluşturup o insanların seslerini
insanlara Ama özellikle yetkililere
gösterebileceğini düşündüm gün sokakta
yaşayan insanları çekebilmem içinde
stratejiler belirlemem gerektiğini
Anladım şöyle yapmıştım sokakta
fotoğrafını çekmek istediğim insanı
gördüğümde elime bir sigara alıyordum
yanına gidiyordum ve ateşin istiyordum o
ateşini aldıktan sonra Sigaramı
yapıyordum Bir sigara da ona veriyordum
ve o karşılıklı sohbetten sonra
fotoğrafını çekiyordum sokakta yaşayan
köpekli bir adamsa izin isteyip önce
köpeğin fotoğrafını çekiyordum sonra
ikinizin fotoğrafını çekebilir miyim
diyordum
bu Eğer çocuğu olan bir an Neyse önce
çocuğun fotoğrafını çekiyordum Sonra
ikisini birlikte çekiyordu Ateş başında
ısınan sokakta yaşayan bir adamsa
üşüdüğümü söylüyordum biraz ısınabilir
miyim diyordum Daha sonra Ateş başında
Onun da fotoğrafını çekiyordum
bu gece yarısı çok farklı Hayatlar vardı
işlerinde Mesela bir tanesi eşref-i
Eşref
Osmanbey Şişli Mecidiyeköy otobüs
durakları arasında uyuyan bir adamdı
kambur bir adamdı Eşref hiç yapmazdı hep
oturduğu yerde uyuyordu
Sen benim hayatımda gördüğüm en
profesyonel socarda sokakta yaşayan adam
Değişti çünkü çok Soğuk havalarda
donmamak için beş dakika uyuyordu sonra
öbür otobüs durağına geçiyordu sonra
öbür otobüs durağını Ben Eşref'in
fotoğraflarını çekerken
reklam tabelaları ile birlikte
çekiyordum Çünkü reklam tabelalarında
vadedilen hayatla Eşref'in hayatının
tezatın Fotoğraflarıma yansıtmak
istiyordum beş yıl boyunca işletim
fotoğraflarını çekmiştim fotoğraflara
baktığınızda Eşref'in pantolonu
değişiyordu ayakkabısı değişiyordu
ceketi değişiyordu saçı sakalı uzuyordu
kalıyordu ama hayatı hiç değişmiyordu
bu fotoğrafa yeni başlamıştım bir gece
aracımda müşteri varken Osmanbey'de
Yerde yatan bir adam gördüm durdum ve
hemen fotoğrafını çekmeye gittim
fotoğrafını çektim tekrar acıma
geldiğimde müşteri çok şaşırmıştı ne
yapıyorsun dedi sokakta yaşayan
insanların fotoğraflarını çekiyorum
dedim ben de fotoğrafçıyım dedi Mimar
Sinan Üniversitesi fotoğraf bölümü mezun
olduğunu söyledi bi fotoğraf larına
bakabilir miyim dedi çektim ilk elli
kare fotoğraftı
bu gösterdim kendisine tek tek baktı
bende de Türkiye'den ve dünyadan
tanımadığım fotoğrafçı yok Bu
fotoğraflar hayatımda gördüğüm en ilginç
fotoğraflar bir karma sergi gibi
yapabilir mi insanı açar mısın dedi Ben
de kendisine teşekkür ederek Ben ileride
kişisel bir sergi açmak istiyorum
demiştim
2004'ten 2017ı Ne kadar altı yıl gece
sokakta yaşayan insanların
fotoğraflarını çektim fotoğrafa
başladıktan sonra fotoğrafçı kimliğiniz
ve kişiliğiniz de oluşmaya başlıyor bu
vesileyle Ben diğer ötekileri de çekmeye
başlamıştım
trans bireyler hayat kadınları
tinerciler baliciler Kağıt toplayıcıları
Benim fotoğraftaki arşivimi oluşturmaya
başlamıştı o ilk çok ilk çektiği
fotoğrafları o dönem oldukça popüler
olan fotokritik sitesinde paylaşmaya
başladım fotokritik Sitesi 800 bin
civarında üyesi olan Türkiye'nin tek
fotoğraf Sitesi ydi Türkiye'de ne kadar
Amatör profesyonel fotoğrafçı varsa
hepsi fotokritik sitesinde üyeydi
ama ben fotoğrafları arka arkaya
paylaştığımda
çok kısa zamanda fotokritik sitesinde
çok tanınan popüler bir fotoğrafçı
olmuştum Çünkü benim paylaştığım
fotoğrafların daha önce Türkiye'de
çekilmemiştir ve dünyada da pek örneği
yoktu
fotoğraflarım ilk olarak ODTÜ Mezunları
Derneği'nin dikkatini çekti ODTÜ
Mezunları Derneği benden bir fotoğraf
gösterimi ve söyleşi istedi ODTÜ
Mezunları Derneği nde yaptım fotoğraf
gösterimi ve söyleşi basının çok
ilgisini çekmişti birçok televizyon
kanalında röportajları yayınlandı
Türkiye'deki bütün ulusal kanallarda
gazetelerde tam sayfa röportajları
yayınlanmıştır
O benim için ilginç anılardan bir tanesi
de Boğaziçi Üniversitesi nde söyleşiye
gidiyordum
bir yerlerde ve duvarlarda okula
geldiğimde ilgili afişler vardı ama
benim için en ilginç olan küçükken
Bekçinin bizi kovaladığı Çitlenbik
ağacında bir afiş vardı dünyaca ünlü
fotoğrafçı Şevket şahintaş okulumuzda
diyordu bu anımı hiçbir zaman unutamam
Mıştım
bu fotoğraflarımı Ankara Üniversitesi
iletişim fakültesinde gecenin öteki yüzü
ismiyle arşivlendi Rusya'da Saint
Petersburg'da Türkiye'den çeşitli
fotoğrafçılarla birlikte Çağdaş Türk
fotoğrafını temsil ettim
İngiltere'de bir üniversitede
bu ara Güler ve benle de röportaj
yapılarak ikimizin fotoğrafa ve hayata
bakışına dair bir Master teyze konu
olmuştur
Bu 2009'da ilk fotoğraf sergim açtım
gecenin öteki yüzü ismiyle
2010 yılında hayatını anlatan belgesel
Antalya Altın portakal'da en iyi ilk
belgesel ödülünü aldı
ve yurt dışında basın liste giderek
artmıştı bir taksicinin sokakta yaşayan
insanların seslerini duyurabilmek Ne
hayali gerçek olmaya başlamıştı 2010
yılında
ve CNN International bir gün boyunca her
saat ana haber Ana Haber öncesi
Benim üç buçuk dakika belgeselini
yayınlayarak ana Haber'e girmişti
Böylece o taksicinin sokakta yaşayan
insanların seslerini duyurabilmek hayali
bütün dünya tarafından duyulmuştu
var Ancak bu başarıydı başarı Neydi o
taksicinin hayali gerçek olmuştu Ama bu
bir başarı değildir Çünkü sokakta
yaşayan insanlar için hiçbir şey
yapılmamıştı bir fotoğraf dünyasında
şöyle bir cümle vardır
çektiğiniz fotoğrafın altına Hiçbir şey
yazmayacak mısınız Fotoğraf her şeyi
kendisi anlatacak Eğer böyle düşünürsek
ben iyi bir fotoğrafçı
olamamıştım Çünkü ben sabaha karşı
üşüyen insanların fotoğraflarını
çekerken inleme sesleri geliyordu Ama
benim fotoğrafımı bakan insanlar oynama
sesini hiçbir zaman duymamıştır
bir Fotoğrafını çektiğim insanların
Hayat hikayelerini
almamıştım 2017'de belgesel sinemalarını
çekmek için tekrar geriye döndüm dört
yıl boyunca çekimler yaptık sokaktaki
yaşayan insanların Kendi Dertlerini
kendilerinden dinlemek istemiştim çözüm
önerilerini gene kendilerinden dinlemeyi
istemiştim ancak Arap anda mi girdi ve
maddi sıkıntılar olunca YouTube'da öteki
sokağın çocukları ismiyle e çektiğimiz
bölümleri yayınladı
bu çekimler esnasında
Melek abla ile tanışmıştık mesela Melek
abla Gezi Parkı'nda köpekleriyle yaşayan
bir abla aydı Aslında gerçek ismi Melek
değildi Biz ismini Melek demiştik çünkü
saat 10'da 11'de Beyoğlu'nda kapanacak
dükkanları biliyordu lokantaları
bu sokakta lardan artan Yemekleri
poşetlerle alıp Gezi Parkı'nda kaldığı
yere taşıyordu ve
onları orada kedilerin köpeklerin ve
kuşların yiyeceği şekilde ayırıp
köpekleriyle beraber uyuyordu sabah
uyanmadan zaten yüzlerce Martı Gezi
Parkı'nın üstünde uçuyordu bazı Martılar
konmuş bir şekilde Melek ablanın
kalkmasını bekliyordu Melek abla kalkar
kalkmaz önce martıları
sonra sokak sokak cadde Cadde gezerek
Kedi ve köpekleri doğuruyordu sokaklarda
karşılaştığımız çok küçük yaşta
çocuklarda vardı Hayat hikayelerini
kendilerinden dinlemişti birçoğu da yurt
çocuğuydu
bu mesela Samet'le bir sohbet ediyorduk
yanında gene yurttan kaçan çocuklar
vardı Samet dedim bak çok soğuk hava
Oğlum neden dışarıda kalıyorsunuz şimdi
yurtta olsanız
O ne güzel kalorifer lerimiz olacak
sabah öğlen akşam yemekleriniz olacak
ama bak Burada şu anda nerede
yatacağınız belli değil bana dedi ki abi
Sokaklar yurtlardan daha güvenli çok
şaşırmıştım neden dedim abi dedi 12
yaşında çocuklarla 18 yaşındaki
çocukları bir arada bırakıyorlar böyle
olmuyor abi dedi Biz büyük abilerden
dayak yiyoruz tacizcilerden bahsettiler
ve devletin verdiği üç beş kuruş parayı
abilerin ellerinden Ala bildiğinden
bahsettiler Aslında çözüm önerilerinde
kendileri söylediler abi dedi 12 14 14
16 16 18 yaşında olsa biz kaçmayız ama
12-18 olmuyor abi dediler
ama Bizler bu çocuklara insan olmanın
gereği olarak yardım etmeliyiz Eğer
insan olmanın gereği olarak yardım
etmiyorsak bir gün o çocuklarla kendi
çocuklarımızın yollarının kesişme
bileceğini asla unutmayalım insan
hayatını bitiren rayı bu olarak düşünün
hepimiz Hayata bir tren rayında
başlıyoruz Kimimiz uzun Kimimiz kısa o
tren rayında hayatımızı geçiriyoruz
annesi babası olan çocuklar Hayata
başladıklarında bir hata yapıp raydan
çıktıklarında anne baba alıyor ve tekrar
oraya yerleştiriyor daha sonra tekrar
çıkarsa tekrar alıyor hayatı öğretiyor
ve o çocuk Orayı da hayatımın sonuna
kadar yaşıyor annesi babası olmayan Bu
çocuklar buraydan bir kere çıktığında O
Çocukları oradan alıp oraya tekrar
yerleştirecek bir sistem yok maalesef
bu Muhammed vardı Mesela Taksim
Meydanı'nda kalan yüzlerce çocuktan
biriydi
o mavi gözlü çelimsiz ben çok severdim
Muhammed'e Sokak Kedisi gibiydi
Hakan isminde bir arkadaşı vardı ama
Muhammed genelde tek takılırdı
bu çekimler esnasında her fırsatta
Muhammed'in yanına giderdik bir şeyler
yer içer sohbet ederdik Muhammed Taksim
Meydanı'nda kalırdı o sırada buradan
Cami büyümeye başladı Muhammed yerde
yatıyordu cami inşaatı büyüdü Muhammed
yerde yattı ve cami inşaatı bittiğinde
Muhammed artık yoktu Sonra bir sene
kadar sonra duyduk Muhammed Hakan'la
birlikte bir cinayet işlemişler ve
o hapisteyim işler bir Peki bu cinayetin
suçlusu kim bunca çabalarıma rağmen bunu
görmeyen yetkililer mi
bu sokakta gördüğümüz de eline birkaç
kuş kuruş verip Gelip Geçen Bizler mi
Biz bu problemi biliyoruz neden de
biliyoruz bir sonraki cinayetinin
suçlusu Biz olmayalım
[Alkış]